du monde de football que la fête
commence dés géants représentant les
continents converger vers les champs
elysées pour le début de cet événement
planétaire et pour les téléspectateurs
de france 2 en exclusivité peu les
invités de ce journal celui qui reste la
légende vivante du football sécheresse
dans le monde l'amérique inquiète
l'année 97 a été l'année la plus chaude
depuis six ans en est en ce moment là on
croule sous la canicule plus de 50
degrés à l'ombre
à six jours du bac tout ce que vous
voulez savoir sur les aides aux
candidats aide mémoire multimédia et les
bons vieux cours de bachotage bac
business c'est notre enquête de ce soir
simple secret c'est le film de la
semaine une tragi comédie sur le thème
du don d'organes avec une affiche
éblouissant meryl streep diane keaton
leonardo dicaprio madame monsieur
bonsoir cette fois ci nous y sommes la
france et paris sont déjà en état de
fait
à la veille de l'ouverture officielle de
la coupe du monde de football en fin
d'après midi dans les rues de la
capitale
quatre géants représentant les
continents européen asiatique africain
et amérindiens ont commencé à converger
vers les champs elysées pour symboliser
le caractère planétaire de cet événement
qui va durer un mois pendant lequel la
france sera la capitale du monde
sébastien guibert thibault de barbeyrac
le géant d'afrique a gardé ses 20 mètres
de plastique et de métal plié pendant
des heures enfants et parents ont donc
longtemps longtemps attendu qui les
jette enfin sur eux son regard de géant
et qu'il les émerveille moussa
l'africain a donc entamé devant la tour
eiffel sa longue traversée de paris
direction place de la concorde
rendez vous chargé de symboles l'amitié
des peuples autour d'un spectacle
gigantesque et détonnant étrange
création à la française sur les champs
elysées l'avenue mythique c'est
naturellement que les supporters
étrangers se sont donnés rendez-vous
argentin écossais tunisien premier tour
de fait
champion du monde de l'ambiance déjà les
brésiliens
s'assagissent tv de la jaguère de
baisers pour venir ici vraiment c'est
très chouette que les pauvres d'être à
chaleur aux extraits des amas les nie
pas les problèmes vous trouvez que les
français sont aimables voyez beaucoup
france et aimable et que c'est
folklorique américain politique
je viens de la capitale de la musique
aux états unis nashville dans le
tennessee
c'est le berceau de notre futur
président al gore pablo le géant
américain vient dort encore sous les
regards admiratifs
c'est une idée géniale
alors que ces quatre robots qui
représente la paternité
tous les continents et qui se rejoignent
comme ça la concorde
c'est une idée géniale ambiance du monde
je pense est ce qu'on attendait on est
servi aux légataires gâtés on espère
l'être à partir de demain
les supporters ont bien commencé sur les
champs elysées on compte maintenant sur
les joueurs brésiliens et écossais et
sur le passage des géants nous
rejoignons tout de suite françois babin
françois way dernier en tout cas je peux
vous dire que le spectacle surtout sur
les trottoirs les sons
un lot de vraies
il devrait passer
voilà je crois que on a une idée de
l'ambiance qui règne actuellement sur
les champs-elysées j'espère que nous
pourrons un jour françois leur nom une
originalité qui n'est pas passée
inaperçue aujourd'hui à paris pour
assurer la sécurité du défilé que vous
venez voir la police a créé une unité de
policiers se déplaçant en rollers par la
suite
cette unité que vous voyez sortir de la
préfecture de police encadrera
régulièrement des manifestations
sportives qui exige vous comprenez un
déplacement rapide le match inaugural
qui aura lieu demain sur france 2
opposera le brésil à l'ecosse le brésil
une nouvelle fois grands favoris de la
compétition les brésiliens qui cet après
midi ce sont allés tâter la pelouse du
stade de france laurent frédéric bollée
roger motte qui a dit qu'entre
supporters on ne pouvait pas fraterniser
quentin brésilien rencontre un écho
c'est aux abords du stade de france ça
donne un truc qui ressemble à du troc un
béret écossais contre un maillot de la
sélection tout le monde est content au
même moment plusieurs centaines de
journalistes se pressent dans la tribune
de presse c'est normal du stade de
france
comme d'habitude l'été les reporters
s'en donnent à coeur joie et nous
explique tout par le détail il faut dire
que ça y est ronaldo et les siens
foulent enfin la pelouse magique celle
qui les verra ouvrir la compétition
demain
aussitôt ça crépite ça flashe ca
observent et sa dissèque l'entraînement
sous toutes les coutures
dans ce premier contact avec le stade de
france pas de problème un mini match
entre dix joueurs est organisée il y a
déjà des buts
les journaux brésiliens répercuteront la
nouvelle pour ce qui est de ronaldo a
noté un tir à côté
seul dans ce cas le défenseur hal dahir
est forfait pour demain il n'y a pas
trop lieu de s'inquiéter
en réalité cette fois ça y est avec
cette présence au stade de france les
brésiliens sont entrés dans la
compétition l'ambiance d'ozoir la
ferrière on a peut-être pris un coup ces
images datent d'hier et c'était la fête
un dernier entraînement aussi en quelque
sorte pour les supporters son rang de
grandissime favori le brésil le doit en
grande partie à la présence de son
attaquant ronaldo à 21 ans ce joueur est
le plus cher du monde transférait de
barcelone à l'inter de milan en italie
peau 180 millions de francs
alexandre cas
le brésilien ronaldo n'est pas un simple
joueur de foot c'est un artiste une star
même ceux qui détestent le football le
connaissent et pour lui le football
c'est bien la chose la plus importante
au monde
la coupe du monde c'est ma motivation
tout l'argent de la terre nous donnera
jamais le bonheur que l'on a lorsque
l'on gagne la coupe du monde à 21 heures
ronaldinho comme le surnomment
affectueusement les brésiliens est le
joueur le mieux payé de la planète
c'est une étoile du sport qui fait la
une des magazines et enflamment des
millions de supporters et pourtant il
garde les pieds sur terre
l'argent je l'utilisé lorsqu'il le faut
c'est sale et les gens donnent à ceux
qui en ont besoin c'est notamment à des
associations pour lesquelles ma mère
travaille le kéké qui est qu'est
issu d'un milieu modeste sa vie n'a pas
toujours été facile
il n'était pas premier en classe mais
toujours en avance à l'entraînement
quand j'ai commencé à jouer c'était très
dur je devais me lever à 6 heures du
matin il fallait prendre deux bus pour
aller à l'entraînement et je n'avais pas
toujours assez d'argent pour payer les
tickets mais pour ronaldo le plus beau
souvenir est loin des terrains c'est
celui d'une rencontre à rome avec le
pape
normal pour l'enfant du plus grand pays
catholique du monde jamais j'en ai
ressenti une telle émotion jamais même à
l'occasion d'un jour là je tremblais et
que tu sois numéro un du couple ouvriers
le tap 13 de la même manière à la veille
du match d'ouverture de la coupe du
monde le brésil écosse ronaldo se montre
confiant pour lui il n'y aucun doute le
brésil sera en finale
et si ronaldo n'est pas superstitieux il
aime les symboles il faut avoir le
brésil dans son coeur mais
personnellement je le porte à l'oreille
même si le brésil ne s'impose pas au
monde ronaldo lui n'a pas vraiment à
s'en faire le monde est déjà à ses pieds
venez bonsoir vous avez répondu à notre
invitation merci on vient de voir un
reportage sur ronaldo la vedette de
l'équipe du brésil ronaldo est-il votre
successeur oui je pense que ronaldo a
une grande opportunité de moins que le
meilleur joueur actuel comparer ronald
bourges avec payless c'est une met une
très grande pression sur lui parce que
les gens attendent quoi le meilleur et
je suis certain questionnement aussi ton
ferme le marquage de but
je pense que l'heure on adoré nous
verrons tout faux pas de trop par les
cromary l'eau qu'elle ait aucune barre
parce que les styles sont différents
je pense en tant que région que ronaldo
sera le meilleur joueur le suis vraiment
le grand favori de cette coupe du monde
de football non le brésil est
certainement un des meilleurs équipes
nous avons les meilleurs joueurs du
monde visuel joueurs brésiliens jouent
en europe et ce qu'il faut à l'équipe le
président c'est de jouer une équipe unie
zagallo l'entraîneur n'a pas eu le temps
de créer cette équipe
cette union libre donc
il faudra qu'ils résolvent des problèmes
pendant laquelle sont les chances de
l'équipe de france risque
je pense que tous les types les équipes
européennes dont sont d'un niveau très
semblables nous avons un très bon niveau
du monde d'attaquant d ailleurs nous
savons aussi tard france qui m'a du
matériau en italie nous avons pas très
bon voir dans cette coupe mais lâche
entraînements et à jouer chez elle et
elle aura une opportunité exceptionnelle
de finale toujours approché de la finale
mais n'a jamais su gagner la coupe du
monde c'est la dernière coupe du monde
de société je pense que la france a de
bonnes chances de la gagner
pelé comment expliquez-vous que 20 ans
après que vous ayez terminer votre
carrière vous soyez toujours aussi
populaire auprès de toutes les
générations d'amateurs de football a few
je suis très heureuse et tout ça car je
n'ai arrêté il ya 25 ans que j'ai arrêté
de jouer et a tellement mais les enfants
de 5 même temps mais crise
ils veulent me voir ils me demandent des
autographes to see me rend très heureux
naturellement il faut comparer avec
d'autres joueurs
il faut comparer avec ce qu'ils ont fait
il faut qu'une phase plus de 1000 buts
en 17 ans
qui ne joue 25 ans il faut beaucoup
grand nom dans l'histoire vous avez un
beethoven c'était un picasso avaient à
frank sinatra
c'est la vie mais vous demandez tout de
même avant de nous quitter un pronostic
la finale de cette coupe du monde cette
coupe du monde sera très vite poussé
vous garantir le prêt est difficile à
redire ce grand final
merci appelé qui vient donc de nous
accorder il ya quelques instants à peine
cette interview en exclusivité
il sera demain pelé au stade de france
pour l'ouverture du mondial retransmis
en direct sur france 2 tout au long de
l'après midi suivi du match brésil
écosse l'équipe de france jouera son
premier match elle vendredi aujourd'hui
à l'entraînement zinedine zidane est
apparu en bonne forme physique vous le
voyez la crainte provoquée par sa
blessure au tibia droit semble pour
l'instant oublié souhaitons lui bonne
chance
après le brillant la république le
premier ministre lionel jospin à
l'occasion d'un séjour à lisbonne a
donné son impression lui aussi sur
l'équipe de france de football faisant
allusion à son propre parcours politique
il a expliqué que c'est au moment des
échéances et non à l'entraînement qu'il
faut être bon
jean michel carpentier patrick démunis
quand un premier ministre rencontre un
autre premier ministre de ses amis ils
se confient à lui
préoccupé par air france lionel jospin
qui passera une bonne partie de sa
visite à lisbonne au téléphone mais pas
seulement
c'est vrai monsieur le premier ministre
pas désagréable cette balade au bord du
tage malgré les soucis d'air france ou
matignon on n'entend pas céder au
chantage des pilotes sur le mondial
tient le foot justement parlons-en voilà
de quoi se changer les idées
allez la france mais toujours à la mode
jospin sans excès supporters oui
absolument chauvin absolument pas c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut extirper du
sport comme il faut l'extirper de
l'idéologie par contre je pense que
l'équipe de france en compétition n'aura
rien à voir avec l'équipe de france les
matches de préparation c'est une toute
autre équipe le degré de motivation va
être incomparablement plus grand et on
va retrouver je crois les très grands
professionnels qui s'illustre dans les
clubs étrangers
donc je ne les laisse pas influencer par
ce qu on a vu des matchs préparatoires
d'ailleurs aucune des grandes équipes
n'a fait jusqu'ici des trios parole de
connaisseur semble-t-il car tout petit
déjà
j'ai commencé ma carrière sportive comme
ball effectivement avant de passer au
basket comme je suis en plus d'un pays
de rugby et que barthez vient de
toulouse
je suis tout à fait derrière lui parce
qu'il est à la fois extrêmement
concentrée près décontracté et il prend
le sport comme il doit être pris c'est à
dire fondamentalement comme un jeu et un
dernier pronostic final avec avec les
brésil
le conflit à air france maintenant il va
donc se poursuivre pendant la coupe du
monde mais finalement son importance
s'est quelque peu réduit sur le plan
strictement opérationnels en définitive
pendant la coupe du monde la compagnie
n'avait qu'un peu plus de cent mille
personnes à transporter et un certain
nombre d'affrètement extérieurs ont
permis de limiter les dégâts pour autant
la compagnie elle même est en difficulté
pour tenter de pallier les effets de
cette grève dominique barrouche alain
poirier les tapis à bagages vide
les trois quarts des vols annulés alors
que le pays entre dans la frénésie de la
coupe du monde
la grève des pilotes continuent de
paralyser les avions même en concentrant
ses vols sur les villes des matches le
transporteur officiel du mondial doit
déclarer forfait sur les jours sensibles
par exemple la veille d'un match en
direction du match le lendemain du match
au retour nous le mettons actuellement à
peu près la moitié de la capacité prévue
à l'origine pour transporter les
footballeurs comme l'exigent le contrat
conclu avec le comité d'organisation
air france a réservé trois de ces
appareils et surtout trois équipages
tous volontaires
impossible en revanche pour
l'acheminement des sponsors et des
supporteurs d'affréter des appareils à
d'autres compagnies en dehors de quatre
avions réservé il y a 6 mois un manque
d'avions disponibles c'est l'été et
manque de pilotes
il est aussi un problème de pilote car
il peut exister ici ou là et on le
comprend bien
une certaine solidarité entre les
pilotes du monde entier qui peuvent
rechigné à remplacer au pied levé
les pilotes d'air france la solidarité
est parti de france où des syndicats ont
donné des consignes aux pilotes de brit
air air liberté ou corsair notamment de
ne pas servir de briseurs de grève
un mot d'ordre également suivi à
l'étranger ces consignes mais l'on
substitution existent à travers
le monde entier c'est à dire que les
pilotes de delta airlines ont refusé de
faire des vols première france tous les
syndicats qui sont membres de l'ifalpa
respecte cette pensée solution trouvée
par aol ou british airways notamment
remplacer des petits avions par des dc10
voir des 747 toutes compagnies
confondues le trafic coupe du monde
reste près de 20% inférieure à la
normale et puis le vent semble tourner
la direction d'air france ce ne semble
plus aussi pressé de sortir du conflit
pas de nouveau rendez vous avec les
syndicats de pilotes et un conseil
d'administration fixé à samedi matin
seulement aidé but également de
contestation du mouvement de grève des
pilotes par les autres catégories
le personnel de l'entreprise ludovic
fossat eric de la dix neuvième jour de
grève est toujours aussi peu de
passagers mais de plus en plus
d'inquiétude parmi le personnel au sol
de la compagnie inquiétude et
mécontentement
enfin nous on le sait nos charges de
travail pour ça se passe le mieux
possible par derrière
démoli ont démoli l'image de la
compagnie donc forcément on s'apostrophe
sentir solidaire de gens qui me semble
être au travail
un mec maintenant qu'ils gagnent aussi
les hôtesses et les stewards
il estime avoir fait beaucoup d'efforts
suite au plan de redressement de 1995
nous gagnons moins 22% par rapport aux
anciens contrats nous voulons davantage
donc nous sommes davantage productif
nous avons largement participé au
redressement de la compagnie c'est en
fait une association s'est même créé
aujourd'hui afin de défendre les
intérêts des salariés la compagnie
demande de revient on demande simplement
que dans cette entreprise de la règle
démocratique sapli c'est à dire que l'on
ne soit pas l'otage de 7% du personnel
alors que par ailleurs il existe des
milliers de personnels qui ont envie de
travailler qui ont besoin de cet emploi
parce que eux ont besoin aussi de vivre
l'opposition à l'agréable gagneraient
donc du terrain pourtant les pilotes ne
se sentent pas affaibli et
son père français
moi
man se durcira des pilotes qui se disent
prêts à négocier
même si la direction n'a toujours pas
confirmé la date du conseil
d'administration fixé samedi matin la
grève des agents de conduite autonome
prévue demain ne devrait pas selon la
direction de la sncf perturber
notablement le trafic ferroviaire en
france grève de 24 heures reconductible
ne touchera pas en particulier les
grandes lignes tgv
le conflit entre les ouvriers des
arsenaux militaires de toulon et le
ministère de la défense qui a décidé de
faire réparer un navire de la marine
nationale par un chantier privé tourner
vous le voyez à l'épreuve de force aux
manifestations successives se sont
substitués aujourd'hui des affrontements
sérieux entre forces de l'ordre et
manifestants devant la préfecture du var
au total 21 blessés dont trois plus
sérieusement touchés parmi les forces de
l'ordre qui étaient présents sur place
devant la préfecture
depuis hier les convoyeurs de fonds de
deux principales sociétés françaises
ardia les brink's se sont mis en grève à
l'appel du syndicat cfdt en question
l'insécurité grandissante dans la
profession c'est dans le sud du pays que
le mouvement est le plus suivi des eaux
lamberton pascal pons pour leur première
manifestation ils n'étaient pas très
nombreux dans les rues de nîmes
et pourtant le conflit des convoyeurs de
fonds peut devenir redoutable en coupe
du monde
en grève illimitée depuis hier ils
dénoncent l'insécurité grandissante dans
leur profession douze morts en sept ans
cent trente sept agressions l'an dernier
cet homme a été blessé par cette balle
lors d'une attaque en octobre dernier
un cas comme le mien ça arrive beaucoup
plus souvent qu'on le croit le monde
souvent dans les groupes à une fois de
temps en temps malheureusement un
auditoire se tire pas trop mal encore
avait des petits c'est qu'elle sait
qu'elle est des fois c'est l'amour c'est
une drogue avait des grosses pour 5000
pour catherine bahl voilà c'est prendre
un contrat 30 heures au moins de 4000
francs par mois à nîmes comme à
montpellier la grève est suivie à plus
de 80% à l'instar d'autres professions
les convoyeurs ont choisi de se servir
du mondial pour exiger une table ronde
avec le gouvernement sans état d'âme en
attente et avant ça pas marché on n'a
pas été écouté on nous a pris à la
rigolade
et voilà on espère qu'avec le mondial
c'est malheureux c'est si triste mais on
espère que cela n'arrive hélas on espère
que le monial sera l'ampleur du score le
plus important un petit peu en otage
tout le monde tu te pour l'instant les
banques reste sereine car elles peuvent
tenir une dizaine de jours mais si la
grève des convoyeurs devait durer au
delà les billets de banque pourrait
devenir aussi rares que ceux de la coupe
du monde
un attentat contre un local du front
national de marseille la nuit dernière a
fait deux blessés légers il a été
revendiqué par un mystérieux groupe de
francs tireurs partisans
cet attentat a eu lieu le jour même du
début du procès qui mettent en cause des
membres du front national en février
1995 en effet pendant la campagne pour
l'élection présidentielle
un lycéen marseillais de 18 ans
d'origine comorienne étaient abattus en
pleine nuit après une altercation avec
des colleurs d'affichés du fn
le meurtrier présumé et ses complices
sont jugés donc depuis ce matin par la
cour d'assises d'aix-en-provence tirer
curtet et cristaux finale l'arme du
crime est la première des deux pièces à
conviction l'autre c'est la fiche de
jean marie le pen que coller les trois
militants du front national cette nuit
là durant dix jours la cour d'assises
des bouches du rhône va tenter de
comprendre pourquoi de ces deux pièces à
conviction est né le drame le meurtre
d'ibrahim ali 17 ans d'origine
comorienne
depuis trois ans les associations
antiracistes entoure la famille de la
victime
pour eux le seul mobile du crime c'est
la couleur de la peau du jeune homme oui
mais là c'est mettre simplement bon ils
sont tirés sur lyokô mentir ceux des
lapins avec des gens des pollueurs voilà
c'est tout
c'est raciste dès le lendemain du
meurtre les trois militants fn ce livre
est de même à la police lors des
reconstitutions robert l'agile l'auteur
du coup de feu mortel n'a jamais varié
qui noir militant frontiste de toujours
il refait les mêmes gestes trois tirs
dont un dans le dos d'ibrahim son
système de défense
cette nuit là il a eu peur il n'y a
aucun élément dans le dossier comme
l'ont motivé les juges et procureurs de
la république de marseille tendant à
accréditer la thèse du crime raciste
sait tous qu'il n'ya pas de propos
racistes il n'y a pas de geste passé
s'il n'y a pas de revendication je ne
défends pas des skinheads indélicats si
les faits sont établis
reste à éclaircir les circonstances a
expliqué pourquoi que moi un homme de 66
ans on vient à se sentir menacés tout
simplement parce qu'un groupe de jeunes
comoriens courait vers lui le président
du front national jean marie le pen cité
comme témoin a dit par écrit qu'il ne
voulait pas venir mais bruno mégret lui
tiendra le 20 mars dernier dans une
colonie de vacances en savoie la petite
ludivine 12 ans originaire du pas de
calais été retrouvée étranglée après
plusieurs jours dans quête le cuisinier
de la colonie de vacances reconnaissait
être le meurtrier aujourd'hui a lieu sur
place la reconstitution du crime didier
guyot philippe esec toute la matinée
devant le juge d'instruction laurent
gass a répété les gestes de la nuit du
20 mars dernier après un début de soirée
bien arrosée le voici déambulant dans
les chambres du centre aéré importunant
plusieurs petites filles comme étant des
attouchements sexuels
puis il emmène ludivine 11 ans laurent
gass a peur qu'elle donne l'alertent il
étrangle le jeune cuisinier a reconnu
tous les faits qui lui sont reprochés
n'est impossible pour lui d'expliquer
son geste
il n'y a pas que l'alcool il y à
l'alcool mais il ya un important
fondamentale troubles de la personnalité
nous sommes comme on dit au tréfonds de
la psychiatrie dans ce dossier on sait
que les enfants les amis de ludivine ont
tout entendu mais terrorisé aucune ne
donnera lé alerte alors les avocats de
l'homme
gace s'étonne qu'un homme puisse ainsi
se promener dans des chambres sans
qu'aucun adulte sans qu'aucun
surveillants entendent quelque chose le
directeur du centre se défend mais
défaut de surveillance été reconnues on
a un fonctionnement impeccable qu'ils
sont les conf as
il ya des gens qui disent en ce moment
il va y avoir des gardiens de nuit mais
j'aurais très bien pu embaucher laurent
gass comme guardian il faut bien être
conscient de ça des psychiatres devrait
bientôt rendre visite à laurent gass
afin de tenter d'en savoir un peu plus
sur ses pulsions sexuelles inexpliquées
mais qui font qu'un soir de mars
ludivine a été étranglée c'est lundi
prochain
oui déjà que commenceront les épreuves
des bacs 81,18 chaque année les
candidats bénéficient d'être
supplémentaires il y a les ouvrages
classiques de révision les nouvelles
techniques multimédias les bons vieux
cours de bachotage et pour la forme la
pharmacie de ces mêmes candidats jean
bernard schmidt jean louis bousquet
enquête dans ses caisses des centaines
des milliers de livres destiné à une
grande librairie au coeur du quartier
latin à paris des livraisons comme celle
ci il y en a une dizaine par jour
nous sommes dans la première librairie
scolaires de france
c'est un exercice précis sans effet
celui ci contient également du court en
cette période de l'année les trois
quarts des ventes du magasin concerne le
parascolaire c'est à dire les ouvrages
qui accompagne l'école en tête du
palmarès les livres de révisions pour le
bac
près de 1500 titres lui sont consacrés
c'est qu'on classe et précis ça permet
de revoir parce qu'on l'a fait dans
toute l'année on y pense toujours pour
avoir son bac ça c'est évident c'est un
enjeu important c'est une porte pour
entrer en fac ensuite donc quelles que
soient finalement le niveau financier de
chacun l'effort est fait nathan premier
éditeur scolaire
ici on travaille déjà sur la collection
90 n'a pas une minute à perdre car les
concurrents sont nombreux
en quinze ans le marché du bac a explosé
le chiffre d'affaires a été multiplié
par sept
il représente plus de 300 millions de
francs de quoi avoir une vraie démarche
marketing et les couvertures c'est le
premier élément qui va faire que l'élève
face à un linéaire où il ya énormément
de titres va être attirés déjà en
premier à avoir envie de prendre les
ouvrages pour le consulter la couverture
c'est important le marché du bac c'est
10 millions d'ouvragés vendus chaque
année
mais il faut aussi penser aux contenus
un objectif l'exactitude des
informations
il ya des erreurs factuelles mais aussi
des offres de conception sur tout le
corps et ce pour ne pas l'esprit du
baccalauréat et à partir de ce moment là
non seulement c'est une dépense qui
correspond pas une nécessité
ça veut se révéler relativement
invisible le marché juteux et nombreux
sont ceux qui voudraient s'y implanter
exemple les éditeurs de cd rom sur 5
millions de programmes éducatifs vendus
en france seulement quelques milliers
concerne le bac les balbutiements
le lycéen restent difficiles à séduire
qu'est ce qui se passe si les portugais
sont meilleurs que les anglais en drap
est meilleur que les ans à côté des
techniques modernes les méthodes
traditionnelles ont toujours la cote
petit groupe bachotage même à 1400
francs la semaine les petits courts sont
de plus en plus prises en 25 ans le
nombre d'organismes de révision est
passé à paris 2-2 à 35 morts ça me fait
progresser surtout ça me fait travailler
sinon je travaillerai pas autant que le
bac il le faut à tout prix ça c'est
clair on a des gens qui sont prêts à
n'importe quoi on sent une grande
pression de la part des parents qui sont
prêts à investir n'importe quelle somme
pourvu que l'enfant ait son bac et pour
arriver en forme aux épreuves vitamines
fortifiant excitant sont proposés à tous
les prix et sans modération ne pas se
laisser berner par des propositions
l'aliment de la mémoire parce que moi je
peux offert des aliments pour le joueur
de boules pour pour tout ce que vous
vous laissez pas passer prendre à sa qui
jouera mieux aux boules
une fois passé le jour j livre candidat
de consulter sur minitel corriger et
résultats du bac de 250 à 5 francs 10 la
minute même après les épreuves les
affaires continuent le département du
gard déclaré ce soir
atteint par la rage après qu'un chien
abandonné morts de la rage et été
déclarée par un vétérinaire de nîmes le
médecin avait reçu récemment une jeune
femme qui lui avait remis de manière
anonyme ce chien abandonné elle pourrait
avoir été mordue et peut-être d'autres
personnes pour l'instant on ignore son
identité elle doit contacter d'urgence
la préfecture du département samedi
dernier dans la loire une fillette de 2
ans est morte d'un coup de chaleur dans
la voiture de ses parents qui étaient
restés en plein soleil la maman une
jeune femme de 19 ans avait laissé la
petite fille toutes fenêtres fermées
chaudement habillés à l'intérieur du
véhicule sous une couverture
ce drame est l'occasion de rappeler que
les enfants n'ont pas plus froid ni plus
chaud que leurs parents caroline glorion
patricia chandelle
une exposition violente et prolongée au
soleil une chaleur excessive et la perte
d'eau qui s'en suit c'est le cocktail
dramatique qui conduit inévitablement au
coup de chaleur chez les enfants à coups
de chaleur qui peut être suivie d'une
déshydratation est un phénomène rapide
et aigus il suffit de moins d'un demi
litre d'eau perdus transpiration et
urine soit 5% du poids d'un nourrisson
pour qu ils se déshydratent et soit en
danger
les choses peuvent aller très vite dans
un coup de chaleur des signes d' alerte
c'est que l'enfant
très vite une conscience qui est altéré
les yeux qui est un peu creux hyper
hyper de l'eau donc il faut prévenir ce
signe d' alerte par des suppléments de
voir quand on a soif c'est découvrir
quand on a trop chaud tout le monde le
fait c'est instinctif chez l'adulte
les nourrissons et les petits-enfants
n'exprime pas forcément ses désirs qui
sont pourtant des signes
alors il faut anticiper et dès qu'il
fait chaud les découvrir comme on le
fait pour soi c'est fondamental
un enfant qui est exposé à la chaleur
doit recevoir des suppléments d'eau dans
son biberon ou par délivrant
complémentaires lorsque la voiture est
l'un des plus grands dangers potentiels
pour l'enfant je crois qu'il est très
important de dire que la voiture une
voiture qui n'est pas climatisé qu'elle
n'y a pas de ventilation et qui est
utilisé par les parents aux périodes
chaudes de la journée est un danger
potentiel
il faut le savoir il est donc absolument
indispensable de faire boire les enfants
durant les trajets et surtout de ne
jamais laisser un enfant seul dans une
voiture même à l'ombre et même pour peu
de temps
c'est le vice président américain al
gore en personne qui a lancé ce cri
d'alarmé l'année dernière a été l'année
la plus chaude aux états unis depuis au
moins six ans avec de nombreux
scientifiques le vice-président
américain est inquiet du réchauffement
global de la planète le phénomène el
niño pourrait en être la cause
à titre d'exemple pour cette année cette
fois ci l'un d'eux traverse une période
de chaleur terrible avec des
températures qui ont atteint 50 degrés à
l'ombre et déjà provoqué la mort de près
de 3000 personnes josé blanc la guerre
ce n'est pas l'eau qu'il préfère
pourtant le tigre ne quitte plus son
bassin dans un zoo du continent indien
c'est pour lui une question de survie
quand la chaleur dépasse les 40 degrés
et qu'elle dure depuis plusieurs
semaines dans la rue la population se
rue sur le jus de canne et le lait de
coco lot de plus en plus rare est aussi
menacée de pollution 3000 personnes sont
mortes de déshydratation l'inde connaît
une canicule sans précédent
alors qu'elle devrait être noyé sous les
trombes d'eau de la mousson depuis plus
d'un an
le climat de la planète ne tourne plus
rond ces incendies qui touchent
actuellement la floride ont été
favorisés par une sécheresse
inhabituelle les états unis subissent
également des records de pluie et une
série de tornades qui a déjà tué 122
personnes le responsable
el niño un réchauffement etc
siph de l'océan pacifique suffisant pour
chambouler le climat
d'après une étude américaine le
phénomène serait accentuée par le
réchauffement de la planète
el niño nous donne un aperçu de cette
météo extrêmement chaotique à laquelle
doivent s'attendre nos enfants et petits
enfants
en tout cas si on ne prend pas des
mesures pour inverser la tendance pour
la première fois la menace de
réchauffement climatique semble prise au
sérieux aux états unis 36 milliards de
francs vont être consacrés à la lutte
contre la pollution urbaine avec une
priorité assainir l'air que respirent la
planète
la sécheresse dans certaines régions du
monde est devenue endémique presque
permanente c'est le cas dans le nord-est
du brésil où les paysans se révoltent
contre les grands propriétaires qui
n'assure pas finalement l'irrigation des
terres
reportage alain de chalvron le nordet le
désert brésilien du sertao grands comme
presque deux fois la france sur des
centaines et des centaines de kilomètres
c'est ce paysage désolé d'arbustes à
moitié mort de maigres herbes sèches de
cactus cette région est a été
caractérisée par est caractérisée par
des sécheresses périodiques qui chaque
cinq à huit années rend les paysages un
corpus sèche des tombes de paysans mort
et enterré là témoignent des ravages de
ces sécheresses périodiques celle des
années 80 habib et les villages du
certains auraient provoqué un exode
dramatique vers les grandes villes du
sud du brésil
cette année le niño aidant cela risque
d'être pire encore on estime que 10
millions de personnes sont en danger de
mort
alors la colère gronde
notamment contre les grandes
exploitations comme celles ci 7000
hectares jusqu'à l'horizon exploitation
c'est beaucoup dire
les propriétaires ont bien essayé jadis
d'irriguer puis ont tout laissé tomber
la terre est en déshérence occasion en
or pour les paysans sans terre poussé
par la famine ils se sont installés sur
le territoire de la ferme et ont
commencé à l'exploiter la loi leur donne
raison
une terre abandonnée peut être reprise
par l'état et redistribuées alors les
sans terre attendent
nous attendons les résultats du
processus d'expropriation et de
redistribution à ceux qui travaillent la
terre
en attendant nous l'avons mise en
exploitation
le campement est devenue ville 700
familles bible à cinq ou six mille
personnes selon les normes brésilienne
le mouvement sans terre et bien
organisés les occupations comme celle ci
il y en a près de 300 dans le certains
hauts et chaque jour des groupes
d'enfants partent en chantant pour
appuyer d'autres actions des pillages du
silo notamment c'est qu'ici la ration
alimentaire est tombé à moins de 500
calories par jour et par personne
et pourtant il n'y a pas de fatalité à
cette misère des comètes des lots dont
27 d'un secteur on peut avoir
on peut avoir une irrigation très
performante très très riches et qui
donne dérivés nitrés très important et
de l'eau ce n'est pas ce qui manque
le fleuve 136 co passe par là et dès qu
on irrigue le désert devient un jardin
d'éden où tout pousse et où personne ne
meurt de faim
une messe anniversaire hier soir à
londres à la mémoire de linda mccartney
mort qu'on avril dernier l'occasion de
réunir les trois beatles encore en vie
son mari paul mccartney ringo starr et
george harrison à l'intérieur de
l'église
les trois membres du groupe le plus
célèbre du monde ont entonné leur plus
grand succès let it be 700 invités triés
sur le volet participaient à cette
cérémonie
s'il est ma sortie cette semaine de
simples secret une tragi comédie sur un
sujet grave pourtant le don d'organes
avec meryl streep diane keaton et
leonardo dicaprio robert de niro
producteur et acteur fait une entrée
rapide dans ce film une affiche en or
ont brillé de l'ère jean louis malle à
la cinquantaine arriver mais rustre et
garde un charme et une fraîcheur intacte
à la voir si réservé presque timide on
en oublie presque qu'en 20 ans de
carrière elle a près de trente films à
son palmarès est déjà reçu deux oscars
méticuleuse elle ne laisse rien au
hasard pas même la musique de son
dernier film simple secret une histoire
de famille assez ordinaire pour
ressembler à celle de notre société
deux soeurs que la ville est différent
sont séparés depuis longtemps vont
devoir se retrouver l'une douce dévouée
est atteint d'une leucémie l'autre
habitués et une indépendance qui
ressemble la solitude se débat pour
élever ses deux fils les mères
célibataires ont une vie difficile aux
états unis en fait elles gardent
l'espoir qu'il ya pour elle un avenir
meilleur plus radieux que de seulement
s'occuper de la famille que cette
promesse est là juste à portée de main
le public américain est très habitué à
ce genre de personnage de cette lutte
contre la mort surgit une émouvante
resson de vie en acceptant de partager
la douleur et l'affliction de cette
famille qu'elle a abandonné la soeur
individualiste va regagner la tendresse
et la confiance de ses propres enfants
girl
cinéma aujourd'hui nous présente des
choses des émotions des gens créent sur
l'ordinateur comme moi je suis un
dinosaure venue d'un temps où ce sont
l'amour et la compassion qui faisait les
films on doit probablement à leonardo
dicaprio et au titanic la sortie en
france de ce petit film produit il y a
deux ans déjà par robert de niro
une chance qui permet de retrouver deux
actrices qui entre humour et drame
sauf créé l'accord juste avant nous
quitter le rappel du principal titres de
l'actualité de ce mardi la coupe du
monde de football la fête a commencé des
géants représentant les continents de la
planète ont convergé vers les champs
elysées demain inauguration et match
d'ouverture brésil écosse en direct sur
france 2 tout au long de l'après-midi
l'événement sur france télévisions
dans un instant la météo sophie davant
je vous souhaite une excellente soirée
sur notre chaîne bonsoir à demain
bon on refait le monde